WHAT A MESS THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE CURRENTLY IS.
HERE FOR REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA ALONG
WITH JOE, LET ME START WITH YOU
IT IS A MESS, AND NOT GETTING
BETTER BUT RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
STARTING TO TALK ABOUT IT TO
THEIR BUDDIES AND THE MEDIA.
>> FIRST, THAT STATS ON 70
PEOPLE HAVING TO MANAGE SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS.
HOW DOES THAT WORK ON YOUR
AVERAGE DAY?
'S GOT IT TODAY?
NUMBER 14?
I THINK 32.
ACTUALLY 69 IT HAS.
70 PEOPLE?
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE TO WORK ALL
THAT MUCH, BUT DYSFUNCTION IN
THIS WHITE HOUSE IS NOT A RECEN
DEVELOPMENT, IT HAS EXISTED FOR
NEARLY A YEAR SINCE AFGHANISTAN
FELL TO THE TALIBAN, MY MAIN
TAKE AWAY FROM THESE PIECES IS
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE SIMPLY
BELIEVES THAT IT HAS MESSAGING
PROBLEM, WHICH IT DOES, BUT IN
THE END PEOPLE DON'T CARE ABOUT
RHETORIC, THEY CARE ABOUT
RESULTS AND THAT RESULTS 60
MONTHS OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
ARE HORRIFIC GREAT INFLATION IS
ALMOST SIX TIMES HIGHER THAN IT
WAS WHEN DONALD TRUMP LEFT
OFFICE.
GAS PRICES HAVE INCREASED 100
PERCENT PURE AT CRIME
CONTINUES TO SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL, LIBERALS ARE MORE
BRAZEN THAN EVER WHEN THEY KNOW
THEY GET ARRESTED THEY'LL BE
BACK ON THE STREET QUICKLY.
THE CATASTROPHE OF THE BORDER
GETS WORSE ALL WITH FENNEL
COMING IN ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS KILLING AMERICANS AT
AN UNPRECEDENTED RATE.
THERE IS NO CUTE HASHTAGS OR
NUMBER STICKER THAT SPINS THIS
INTO EVERYTHING BEING OKAY.
THE VOTERS SEE WHAT THEY SEE IN
FEEL WHAT THEY FEEL,
INCREASINGLY IT'S CLEAR THAT TH
ADULTS ARE NOT BACK IN THE ROOM.
>> IT'S TRUE, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE MANAGE YOUR ACCOUNTS
, BUT I DO KNOW UNDER
DONALD TRUMP, IT WAS ONLY DONAL
TRUMP AND MAYBE DANCE COULD BE
NO, MAY BE TWO PEOPLE ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, NOW IT'S UP TO 70.
THAT RAISES MY NEXT QUALITY
COLLECTION, IT IS A POLICY
PROBLEM, OR IS THIS AT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PROBLEM WHERE
THEY HAVE GONE SO FAR LEFT AND
JOE IS IN THAT BOX, HE'S GOT 70
PEOPLE AROUND HIM MAKING SURE
WHATEVER COMES OUT IS RIGHT DOW
THE LINE, HE CAN'T CHANGE IF HE
WANTS TO, BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
THE HOUSE HE'S BUILT.
>> IT IS THE WHOLE BALL OF WAX
THERE, YOU HAVE A CANDIDATE OR
PRESIDENT WHO IS SIMPLY NOT UP
TO THE JOB HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
PHYSICAL VITALITY TO DO THE JOB.
THEY DON'T TELL HIM THINGS THAT
OUR HAPPENING BECAUSE MY GUESS
IS HE'S NOT IN THAT OFFICE ALL
THROUGH THE DAY.
THEY PICK THROUGH MOMENTS WHEN
HE'S READY TO HEAR THING AND
THEY NEVER GELLED AS TEAM
BECAUSE OF ZOOM IN DOOM AND
THEIR FEAR OF GETTING SICK OVER
THE VIRUS SPREAD HE WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT WITHOUT RUNNING A REA
CAMPAIGN AND HAVING A REAL
OPERATION WHERE PEOPLE BOND.
I'VE BEEN ON THOSE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS AND YOU GET ATTACKED,
THEY DON'T SEEM TO HAVE THAT IT
STARTS WITH KAMALA HARRIS FOR
THE OTHER THING I FIND
ASTOUNDING IS HOW QUICKLY THEY
PROVED THAT SOCIALISM IS CANCER
IN OUR COUNTRY.
THEY USUALLY GET AWAY WITH
TRYING TO SPIN MORE SOFT
PROBLEMS AND BLAME THE
REPUBLICANS FOR THINGS LIKE
SHOOTINGS AND STUFF AND THEY GE
AWAY WITH THAT BECAUSE OF THE
ALLIES AND THE MEDIA BUT THE
PROBLEM IS ALL OF THESE POLICIE
HAVE COMPOUNDED TO THIS
OUT-OF-CONTROL INFLATION THAT I
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS NOTHING THE
CAN DO BECAUSE THEY ALWAYS WANT
TO SPEND MORE TO SALTED AND
COMBINED THAT WITH THE FACT THA
OUR ENERGY CRISIS WHICH AS PART
OF INFLATION HAS EVERYBODY
PANICKED ABOUT WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THEIR JOBS.
LET'S BRING UP ONE LAST THING,
WE ARE NOT EVEN BACK TO THE
EMPLOYMENT RATES HALF A MILLION
JOBSITE OF WHERE WE WERE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC SO THEY CAN TELL U
EVERYTHING IS GREAT, BUT WE'RE
NOT EVEN WHERE WE WERE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AREN'T STUPID.
>> THEY ARE NOT.
JOE, THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORP
FAMOUSLY, AND YOU SEE THE WAY
THEY WENT AFTER TRUMP, USE
EITHER WAY WITH KID GLOVES
TREATED BIDEN, BUT FOR THESE
STORIES TO START COMING OUT, IT
IS ONE THING FOR FOX NEWS TO
TELL THE STORIES, IT'S ANOTHER
THING FOR DC INSIDER
PUBLICATIONS TO START TALKING
ABOUT NOT JUST DYSFUNCTION, BUT
CHAOS.
>> WE FOLLOW SPORTS PRETTY
CLOSELY AND YOU SEE THIS WITH
TEAMS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
PRETTY GOOD GOING INTO A SEASON
SUDDENLY THINGS GO SOUTH IN A
HURRY AND EVERYBODY STARTS
POINTING FIGURES AND THAT'S WHA
HAPPENING NOW, EVERYBODY IS
POINTING FINGERS, BUT THE
WRITING IS ON THE WALL, IT'S
APPARENT THAT THIS WHITE HOUSE
IS ABOUT TO SUFFER HISTORIC
SHELLACKING IN THE MIDTERMS.
THIS IS A MINISTRIES
MINISTRATION VIEW AS INCOMPETEN
AND LOW TO RESPOND TO CRISIS
THESE.
HERE YOU HAVE MORE THAN A FEW I
THE MEDIA WHO SEEMED SURPRISED
THAT WE ARE WHERE WE ARE UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT BECAUSE IN THEIR
JUST TO GET RID OF THE PRESIDENT
, TRUMP, FOCUSING ON
TRUMP, NO ONE TOOK A GOOD LOOK
AT BIDEN AND JUST HOW DECISION
AFTER DECISION HE HAS MADE
WEATHERBY FOREIGN POLICY OR
DOMESTIC HAVE NOT BEEN GOOD ONES
.
>> IT'S TRUE PERIOD, LAST WORD
BROKE QUICK.
>> THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM WITH
THE BIDEN A MINISTRATION IS THE
REASON WHY THEY CAN'T GET OUT O
THIS HOLE IS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY TO GET OUT OF THE HOLE.
THEY CAN'T USE THE PRESIDENT,
VICE PRESIDENT, THEIR POLICIES
SUCK AND THEY'RE GOING TO GET
KILLED IN THE MIDTERM.
AT THINK THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WILL BE SEEN AS A LEFT-LEANING
PARTY.
IT COULD BE A LONG WAY BACK FOR
THEM WHICH I'M ACTUALLY PRETTY
HAPPY ABOUT.
>> ME TOO.